what it is well I'll tell you what it is
it's to raise awareness for America
fundraising Marathon
yeah I know it's a tad bit dramatic I'll
admit that but this is what we got to do
to get eyes on the parts of America that
need our help
hit the music
[Music]
hello I'm Tyrus
and just for 39 cents a day
you could do what our government is
failing to do
like Health East Palestine Ohio or our
agents of the Southern border
they get less support than a friend who
says Let's vacation in Delaware
or provide Michigan with clean drinking
water
there's more heavy metal in there than
Greg's record collection
or help with the homeless and countless
American cities
because most guys camping on the
sidewalk aren't trying to get Taylor
Swift tickets
or you could help feed the struggling
comedians
oh and if you don't help
Katie she might return to her former
career of clubbing baby seals
someone's got to do it
now listen I'm going over the top and
making a big deal out of this like gut
fell when boob gate gets an update
so sick of that am I right cat but hear
me out
and all corners of our country we've got
problems where Americans need help
not to mention onslaught of crime of
mostly peaceful protesters and The View
and what's the federal government or the
White House doing
well they're busy helping other
countries
and picking up Hunter Biden's check and
tab for whatever the hell he's doing
right now
and President Biden he won't visit the
town Ohio they had a train derail and
chemicals spread throughout it
but he's happy to go to Ukraine and give
out another half billion dollars of our
tax dollars in Aid money
we'll have to borrow missiles from them
the next time we're attacked by a hobby
balloon
and the VP Harris she won't go to the
Border probably because she'd rather
take the Magic School Bus to the Moon
you guys are gonna see you're gonna
literally see the craters on the moon
with your own eyes with your own eyes
I'm telling you it is gonna be
unbelievable
with your own eyes
you've got the federal government
picking up the travel and hotel bill for
illegal immigrants
like Hunter giving cab fare to a hooker
but cab fare is what he calls money to
buy him some more crack
right
here isn't going to put its people first
maybe our cities should Outsource for
some help
maybe we could spell ad spaces for
relaxium
[Laughter]
or we we could ask for a big fat check
from Saudi Arabia or China or France
check that not France never France
hell China's buying up half America
anyways why not ask them for a few bucks
or better yet ask them to build us a
wall they've got a great one
hell you couldn't even sell a balloon
over it
or maybe we should ask the Mexican
military to pitch in at the border
because remember the left wanted to
throw our agents horses in The Slammer
for five to ten years for being racist
horses
Biden lied about them using whips like
they were gut fills dominatrix
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Secrets out veto
now you might make sense since a lot of
sarcasms for me right now well you're
not psychic it is
maybe mayor Pete is finally going to the
Ohio train derailment site tomorrow
I wonder if he'll have an SUV drive him
there and then ride the bike the last
few blocks
but guess what Pete you can finally hand
out Mass because now they actually need
them
or let's trick Kamala and tell her it's
the other Palestine and maybe then they
can get some help
tell her she can Evacuate the residents
and lock them up in California
remember she was the D.A over there
time time flies right when you're
getting screwed over
the point is we pay our state taxes for
our state
so why are we paying federal taxes to
see our federal money go everywhere else
but where we need it at home how about
let Americans keep their federal taxes
if we're on our own anyway
or at the very least a few extra bucks
for gas canisters generators and
relocation expenses many Americans will
face Americans deserve better from
Congress and the president they need to
show up for us when it matters most or
at least send us a Dear John Letter and
let us know we're on our own
or at least let Americans claim Asylum
so they can get a spot and a good hotel
food close and National recognition
here he is
let's welcome tonight's guests when she
says oh shoot she really means it Fox
News contributor Katie pavlin
he always looks surprised that he's
still on the Show
comedian Joe Mackey
for 40 days and 40 nights that's how
long he goes between bookings writer and
comedian Joe DeVito
uh she wants her tombstone to say do you
hate me right now Fox News contributor
and cat too
cat welcome to the show thank you so
much for having me I feel like we've
been doing this forever let me as a
Libertarian I specifically brought up
federal taxes yeah and I'm assuming that
you're going to support this because it
doesn't seem like it's going where it
needs to go no and it very rarely does
which is why again you have to laugh in
someone's face who thinks you're a jerk
for saying oh we pay too much in taxes I
don't want to pay this in taxes like you
don't care about supporting people who
need it it's like no no when are these
taxes going to people who need it and
and they also just they lie and they lie
I mean people forgotten about this story
because people in the government have
said it's okay it's fine over there you
can drink the water uh what I've not
seen them do is go there breathe the air
and drink the water which if that was
really true it would be that simple go
over there go to someone's house turn on
the tap pour yourself a big tall glass
of that water and drink it yes and then
wait 30 seconds but they won't but they
will that would be so easy to do and
they won't do it because they know they
know it's not uh I believe Kate Pete
said hit go when the time was right or
is that when he said he enough medical
staff around him to keep him safe you
know how this how I know this
Administration hates the people of East
Palestine is because they're sending
people to judge to handle the problem
after 20 days I mean
if there are any greater punishment than
that I mean Joe Biden would be a
punishment but they're really just
sending the guy who couldn't fill
potholes in in the town that he was the
mayor right vice president's not going
they've acted like this isn't an issue
um you know the federal government does
not do a good job of responding to any
kind of of Crisis you're right about the
taxes but when it comes to solving this
particular problem the EPA has been late
uh the local government has asked for
help from the beginning they've denied
it until president Trump stepped in and
actually went there today and said hey
we're here we want some help
um so you know I don't think Pete Buddha
judge going is going to help anything
and I think it's actually a slap in the
face as you would say yeah it is a slap
in the face next time kiss us first you
know what I'm saying
um
speaking it's it's a classic saying my
grandmother taught it
the Dominatrix and a guy who doesn't
take mess from anybody like do you think
president Trump coming sends a big
message to them to get their stuff
together or is it an excuse for them for
not to go to do more for them well first
I'm not thrilled with the Segways we've
had toward me tonight
uh what are you talking about I got all
the letters it was signed Joe
I'm glad somebody went
you know at least Trump showed up but I
don't know why Biden didn't go he's on
this world tour he's the only person who
those chemicals might actually improve
his health so
I I didn't hear about him having trouble
with trains we know that stairs are a
for him but he could have taken
the train there it it's so ridiculous
I'm going to send mayor Pete there I I
guess they were holding off they want to
make sure the chemicals didn't taint his
breast milk because he likes to go on
his his child leaves this is what this
shows like what we need to do is we
don't need to build a wall around our
country because that's not keeping our
money from from flowing to these other
countries because we don't have it to
spend what we need is a dome we need a
dome over the United States so the
people who are here we can sort out our
problems we don't need new people coming
in to to make things worse or but we
just need to settle our own stuff and at
least a dome would keep the balloons out
I'm with you a thousand percent the only
thing I would ask is if we had a giant
slingshot so we could open and shoot a
few individuals out but other than that
I'm with you Joe you know if you didn't
have to pay federal your federal taxes
what would you do that extra cash like
how would you help America with the
extra bucks you've got coming in
I would donate to your fundraiser As
Long As I Got A Fox Nation tote bag and
some Brian Kilmeade remainder books is
part
I'll have to work on that but but I I'll
have to say I hope the voters of Ohio
and Pennsylvania are paying attention
because uh they're given a hundred
billion dollars to a country that's not
in our interest at all halfway around
the world and all that East Palestine is
getting is some free Vinyl chloride
that doesn't sound like the actions of a
man who knows the suffering caused by
oil cancer
[Laughter]
I know why you don't like you don't like
taking risks so if you had the choice to
go somewhere where a bomb siren was
going off the entire time when you walk
the streets or go to a place that's not
even that far of a ride to go check to
make sure your American citizens are
better wouldn't you think the safer move
would have been to go check on the
people in Ohio first you would think so
also because I mean politics
unfortunately is largely pretending that
you care like that's such a huge part of
it and it's not that it shouldn't be
that hard to pretend that you care uh
when this story came out the first thing
that they tried to do was sort of you
know explain why it wasn't their fault
or you know say oh it's no big deal kind
of minimize it I mean
you're asking for what you you know you
should be doing which is actually
helping these people they haven't even
gotten to you know the protect
pretending to help these people or
pretending that they care about these
people uh they're they're loud and clear
that it seems as though the people who
are suffering there are not useful pawns
for any of their political narratives
therefore they don't really care and
they don't even bother to pretend no
that's a great point that catch is made
do you think it's because Katie because
they're afraid that most of those people
vote Republican in that area but the
reason why they have such a
laissez-faire reaction to it because
honestly if it wasn't for Twitter and
fox no one would know about the story I
also think that the skin tone one of the
people who live in East Palestine is too
white for them yes to be quite honest
um but you know going back to the point
you made about the taxes we give so much
money to the federal government the
government just passed just with
Democrats a trillion dollars in
infrastructure and yet we have
infrastructure failing all over the
country the reality is we do need money
for infrastructure we do need the
federal government to fix a lot of these
things especially trains that go across
state lines the state governments can't
fund themselves but because there's so
much corruption in Washington DC and
lobbying and special interests that
those problems never get solved and it's
in every single aspect of the government
Social Security other government
programs that are supposed to help
specific people and they never do
because they take that money and use it
towards their own pet projects and then
of course they don't care about certain
communities because they're not helpful
politically and for Joe Biden who is the
guy who said I'm going to be the
president for everybody I'm going to be
Mr unify it shouldn't matter that East
Palestine is in a trump District or that
Republicans vote there he should go
there for the sake of hold building up
his own campaign promises and being the
president of the United States not just
the president of the Democratic Party
[Applause]
dropped like a balloon with a note be
back soon too soon for that give us
something away from the window we'd
probably wave on the wrong side before
we go
you can come see me live I'll be at the
Crowley Louisiana April 21st Houston
Texas April 23rd if I'm still breathing
I'll be in Walla Walla South Carolina
May 5th visit the link Tree on my
Instagram for tickets hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else